- As promised, I found
some old photos of you.
Are you ready to go through them?
- Oh boy.
- I'm excited, all right!
- All right, let's see what you got.
- Here is the first one.
Yes!
(audience laughing)
Oh my gosh, how old are you there?
- I think second grade.
- Oh my god, you're adorable.
Look at that.
You had that big old hair going even then.
You were like, "Y'all
ain't ready for my hair."
Okay, next.
Yes!
- Okay.
- I mean, it looks like
you're about to fall
with the horse but you're not.
- Okay, two things,
three things about that.
I've got the reins in the wrong hand.
(laughs)
That is my brother
Peck's calf roping horse,
he wasn't working too good for Peck
so Peck said I could run barrels on him,
and I am rocking the plaid pants.
- Yes you are.
Yes you are ma'am.
Fashion icon before it really even hit.
Okay, next.
- [Reba] That day Kelly, I
won a car for six months.
- [Kelly] What?
- I won a Ford Torino car for six months,
and all you had to do was fill out
your little questionnaire thing,
and then that is the cow wall cowboy
high school band right there.
- Oh my God.
- Oh you see the gal on the right,
Roger Wills.
He is the band leader for Alan Jackson.
- Oh, no way!
- And then Suzie's in the middle,
and Peck on the left.
And Gary Rathburn and Kelly Ryan.
- Your whole family sings.
That's why I find I know that
and I know a lot of people do know that,
but it's insane like I'm talking like
everyone sings like well
Like it's crazy.
- Well daddy, somebody
asked daddy one time,
he said Clark, do you play?
He said I used to play on the linoleum.
(laughs)
- What?
I loved your dad.
- He's a character.
He loved you.
- I love it.
Okay, next.
Okay.
- Oh my gosh.
- Oh, that's Winona.
- And Trisha.
- Is that Trisha?
- Yeah.
Bruce Hinton.
- Oh my gosh, look at Trisha.
She's so cute.
- [Kelly] Look at your hair,
you are so
look at all of y'all
y'all are so cute.
- [Reba] When was that?
- [Kelly] I don't know.
You all have, are those records?
Those are all your records.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
This is what I'm talking about.
See, this is 90's country right here.
Like all these women
representing right now,
and like they don't play women now
hardly on country.
What's wrong with y'all?
- They're missing out.
- I know.
Next.
- [Kelly] This is us!
- [Reba] That was for the duets album.
- [Kelly] It was.
- [Reba] You came and sang with me.
- It was so magical.
It's so funny because
remember we actually recorded
a different song first,
and then we ended up doing Crossroads,
and then we ended up doing Because Of You,
and it was such a magical moment.
- Kelly, we look so young.
- I know.
I still look, I don't
what you're talking about.
- Shut up.
(laughs)
- All right, next.
- [Kelly] I was here.
This is the Kennedy.
- [Reba] The Kennedy Center Honors.
Thank you for coming and singing for me.
- I will do anything for you ever.
- Thank you.
Thank you very much.
- This was really awesome.
- It was a lot of fun.
- I generally don't get nervous,
but I'll tell you what,
I about peed my pants at that one.
- You did great.
- I was nervous.
Okay, next.
- [Kelly] Yes!
(applause and cheering)
Okay, ma'am.
- Well.
- Is this in Vegas?
That's in Vegas.
- Yeah.
- Oh my gosh, next.
(laughs)
I feel bad about myself.
This is awesome.
What's this?
- That's when I was Ben
and no my 40th anniversary
with Ben in the Grand Del Opry.
There's Vince Gill, Dolly
Parton, Carrie Underwood.
(applause and cheering)
That's so sweet.
- Wait, and you're actually
reuniting with Dolly and Carrie.
- Yes, Dolly, Carrie, and I,
we are going to be co-hosting
the CMA Awards this year.
- I love that!
(applause and cheering)
- [Reba] How about that?
- I couldn't think of three
better women to do that.
- Thank you.
I'm thrilled to death that they asked me.
- Yes.
I mean what?
Of course they asked you.
They were like we need a legend.